today's one minute monday is tell your
story
if you want to stand out if you want to
get customers if you want to get people
talking about you then you have
to tell your story i can't tell you how
many websites i go to from entrepreneurs
and you look at their about page and
it's so
boring so boring this is your chance to
stand out guys
if i'm hiring a company say i'm hiring a
landscaping company
okay i'm going to 10 different websites
and one guy is talking about how he
loves landscaping
how his father got it got him into it
how
you know he grew up with landscape and
how he treats every
lawn like it's it's dad's lawn and then
every other landscaping company is
talking about the 10 things that they
offer
services who am i going to go with i'm
going to go with the guy who tells the
story
you started this business for a reason
you're passionate about your company
you're an expert you're one of the best
in the world at what you do let that
come across
let me feel why you started this
business and the deep passion you have
for it
if you make me feel something then i'm
going to want to buy from you
believe you guys like this video thumbs
up
leave a comment subscribe i'll see you
soon